[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der Lehrgruppe Gebirgskampf und
zurzeit befinde mich als Ausbilder auf
ein Heeres hochgebirgsspezialistenkurs
in den Lienz
[Musik]
der Herr ist hochgebirgspezialistenkurs
was man haben bis die zweite Stufe in
unserer Ausbildung die erste Stufe ist
der Heeres gebirgsausbilder wo die
meisten Leute diesen Kurs schon
absolviert haben und eine weiterführende
Ausbildung bis zum Bergführer machen und
wie gesagt dieser zweite Teil was die
Leute jetzt machen im zweistufigen im
dreistufigen Modell Sommersaison
fordert die Leute natürlich es geht
Kleider in die scharfe Gelände wie man
Musik vom Felsen her bis zum dritten
vierten Schwierigkeitsgrad wo der Mann
dann teilweise auch mit der Basis was er
von uns vermittelt bekommt an
Seiltechnik oft auf sich alleine
gestellt ist deshalb haben wir zuerst
einmal eine Ausbildung von dir in Form
von Stationsausbildung wo man den Leuten
das vermittelt oder dann sich die
Sicherheit selber aneignet und alleine
am Standort arbeiten kann man nicht
immer ein Ausbilder tätig hinter ihm
oder ständig hinter dem noch geht und
das wachst mit der Zeit so wird dieser
Party jetzt ist gehen wir dann über in
einer einwöchige Ausbildung noch ca 14
Tage in das verklettert vergletscherte
Gebiet auf die Bereiche
führen am Gletscher und gewisse
Rettungstechniken muss er dann im Eis
hat
stand
[Musik]
aufbauend auf diesen drei Wochen vorher
was der Lehrgangsteilnehmer dann von uns
gelehrt bekommt hat ist dann aus der
Schwergewichte diese gebirgskampfwoche
in der Wartezeit oder dann im Rahmen der
Gruppe Aufgaben zu erfüllen hat wie
überwinden eines gratis in Kombination
muss eine noch einige geht und auch
kombiniert mit einem schafschießen oder
dann vielleicht nicht mehr so mit dieser
Ausrüstung unterwegs ist sondern da hat
er wirklich die gefechtsausrüstung mit
von der Bewaffnung beginnend bis
schwereren Gebäck und hat er Aufträge zu
erfüllen die was noch für ihn sehr
fordern sein werden also teilweise noch
einige geht für ihn unbekanntes Gelände
wo die Absprachen
der Gruppen wo ist die Aufgaben zu lösen
sind nicht so vonstatten gehen wie da
bei durchsprechen sie die Gruppen oft ab
welcher Tour bist du gegangen will
wirklich einen Auftrag für die Gruppe da
werden die Kommandanten durchgewechselt
von uns beurteilt und das ist sicher
noch einmal fordert bevor es dann in die
letzte Woche in die Prüfungswoche
hineingeht
[Musik]
am Ende dieses Lehrganges erfolgt noch
eine zweitägige Prüfung je nach
Situation bekommen die Aufgaben gestellt
wir bauen diese prüfungsstrukturiert auf
das alles was bei der Prüfung erfolgt
der Mann oder die Frau schon einmal
gesehen oder gemacht hat mindestens ist
wiederholt sie öfter er schließt dann
als Heeres hochgepäckspezialist ab
sollte er den winterteil schon haben
dann bekommt er das Abzeichen her das
Hochgebirge Spezialist druckt alles
abzeichnen dafür und es befähigt dann in
weiterer Folge wenn er sich das zutraut
auch weitergehen zum Bergführer und
natürlich in seiner Einheit Leute im
alpinen Gelände zu führen mit denen
erlebnisorientierte alpinausbildung zu
machen und für uns ist es natürlich dann
jederzeit abrufbar und greifbar wenn wir
wieder Kurse leiten wo man sehr gutes
geschultes Lehrpersonal wieder von der
Gruppe bei uns in Saalfelden wieder
brauchen können und ein beide Lehrgänge
wieder einbauen
[Musik]